so today's topic micro cheating so I'll
give you guys a definition of micro
cheap-ass micro cheating is the idea
that you can be cheating on your partner
in a million tiny ways without even
really noticing that you're doing it
where do you establish the fact that it
goes micro to macro so this microchip
just like the little conversation aside
though macro cheating is when I put my
dog inside the girl that's a macro
cheating because you're cheating
flipside check this peep game [ __ ] what
happens if you stick your micro penis
inside a girl is that micro macro
cheating think about it you know we
thought about its Ling Ling [ __ ] Lane
Lane listen you're being micro rude
right now yeah I'm being [ __ ] whoo
because your microaggressions are upset
chilly so look Millennials I'm not like
for a generation I grew up with social
media your PR rep [ __ ] sucks I think
it's the same PR rep for United Airlines
cuz you ninnies do not know what the
[ __ ] you're doing these carbs waning
microaggressions Micro me on this doll
your feelings were a girl oh how you
wanna know Bob's on I will tell you
there anything ways to know when you're
born is micro cheating on you [ __ ] all
I'll say it exactly what you need to
know but I'm not done listen [ __ ] this
[ __ ] like eating patty cake patty cake
patty cake patty cake patty cake
number five logging a girl in his
contacts folder under a Conan
to avoid detection when she calls texts
and emails preachers nickname on my
phone is any King call little Beach you
got TV program series my girl yo Syria
was my name yo Eric but you asked me to
call you hello purposely neglecting to
mention his significant other in a
conversation with the friends and
colleagues he interacts with regularly
so that many of them actually think he's
single maybe I'm a private person
maybe I'll bring it up when no one's
asking yo did you wash it yo this
weekend I was with my girl one of the
motor restaurants as you know that's
what couples in love dude that's my girl
I love her you know I mean all my finger
lady who not my girl I got a ring on it
you know me okay cool did you watch too
much yeah I did with my girl though
haha number 13 closing his eyes when he
needs a minute to escape and date you
about the girl he's crushing on because
she's she's his opium of the moment but
that's just petty days very good who
cares
listen I did dream often about other
woman even while I'm in relation I think
I took off to other members 75% of the
reason why [ __ ] girl is that later
[Music]
I've earned those members let me use
them freely memories are live like
people do they always remember you when
things get good or bad it's just the
memories that we had oh you know the
ring knife and fork a5:p don't blink was
9 + teen Trang you like hide your neck
for I'm not 21 21
like my defense you still
26 gifting his girlfriend with a bottle
perfume his crest wear so that he'll
smell like his latest fantasy chick
creep what the [ __ ] are you dating what
[ __ ] degree 27 keeping a piece of
clothing that reminds him of an ex even
though it's definitely tattered or
completely out of style what do you want
me to say
you know sometimes souvenirs were nice
like sometimes I just pull out a pair of
pants Anders and it makes me feel better
about my date I don't see anything wrong
with that people keep focus on their
walls no no no talk about the fact that
you had a [ __ ] pair of panties
number 32 spending all of his time in
gross and conversations with another
woman at a party or event even though he
brought his girlfriend as his date look
babe hmm I really want to go to a party
tonight sure it's Anita [ __ ] you think
you're going we came out in public so
you can only talk to me excuse me
you're gonna go Micro cheat on me with
Anita [ __ ] yeah go ahead go ahead I'll
beat your ass up we go home with a home
take me home is you're gonna make with
some people or go home don't go home
[ __ ] get the car boo-boo nobody funky
I don't know why you got a place I go to
parties to socialize I get you I see you
all the time I'm with a party to see
people I don't so now I'm the border
party so I'm gonna talk to people number
last one mindfully leaving his wedding
ring at home when he heads out with the
boys not so much because he wants to get
lucky but just because he wants to feel
like it's in the wrong possibility for
him again she doesn't understand the
games my girl was like yo why don't you
put your ring on I like nah be it's
actually worse when I got my ring on
whenever I go see my parents in the
States
and I got my ring on and I'm in the
airport I travel alone I got a ring girl
women want you more than normal you know
I'm single cuz sometimes I wear
everything to go out cuz
Michael cheating is the idea
secrecy I don't think just because
you're dating someone more you married
someone they need to know everything
about what you know me and preacher
friends alright and I'm dating a girl
what if he has a micropenis okay which
is highly possible and as a result he's
embarrassed by there's no want you to
know am i because I'm dating you
supposed to tell you everything about my
friends is life no I made a good point
when you gave me a look like you you
needed some rubbin you need some pretty
honey closing comments you can't pass
another cold that's not informing this
as informative it's not everybody wants
to have [ __ ] educators for every
[ __ ] [ __ ] all that [ __ ] learn to
communicate don't buy into these
lame-ass buzzwords and [ __ ] all this man
spreading man blablabla blabla toxic
masculinity and then on the whites plain
and getting into the able splaining is
Amanda
yeah microaggressions go micro go [ __ ]
yourself [ __ ] so that's it for today's
video be sure to share it like subscribe
comment leave comments cuz we read it
but we never reply if you guys a lot of
follows we got a YouTube Instagram page
on all that stuff you know share it tell
them boom cow yeah dank we also have a
Sunday open mic that happens every week
here monster all details below that see
y'all soon next week you know a dollar
makes me holler